welcome everyone to the data science
hangout
this is the open space for current and
aspiring data science leaders to connect
and chat about some of the more human
centric questions that you all have
around
leadership and we'll focus on questions
that are most important to you all so i
just want to say there's three ways that
you can ask questions so you could jump
in live
you can also put a question in the zoom
chat and i can call on you and pass the
mic over to you
but we also have a slido link as well
which robert will share in just a second
here
and there you can ask anonymous
questions as well
but just a quick note that the session
will be recorded and shared up to
youtube for anyone who's missed it as
well
and i am so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today rami crispin
and rami i am very grateful to who
jumped in here last minute we had a
little uh switch up with
one of the leaders dates and rami was
able to to jump in here
he manages a
data science team
focused on cost optimization and
capacity planning
he's also the author of a hands-on
time series analysis book and several
art packages
i think many of you may have seen rami
on
linkedin and and twitter and from
uh various presentations that he's given
to the community as well
but i'd love to turn it over to you
rami and have you introduce yourself and
chat a bit about some of the work that
you do
thank you rachel thank you for the
invite and thank you everyone that
joined
so i'm ramy crispin i'm a data science
manager at apple
um i'm not representing in this stock up
or cannot talk
on my work up and unfortunately
due to the short time i didn't have the
time to go for the our legal approval
but i will be happy to answer any
general questions about data science and
you know
the life of
uh
you know workflow and life of data
science
i'm
as richard mentioned i'm really active
in the open source community and
since the covet starts mainly on
uh creating packages related to copy 19
data
okay and thank you for the invite at the
beer
definitely thank you rami
and i know we had just a few minutes to
connect before this as well um but would
really love to kick off the discussion
with asking what is something that
you're most excited about in data
science right now
uh
i would say probably like the boeing
stuff that's going on in data science
tools that are coming that related to
production
uh
like you know
the docker and github actions the
combination with all
and
it's it's amazing how
simple is you can today you can take
those uh free and open source tools and
put your own code in production
so i'm
i'm really excited about
you know the
those tools are just coming the more
tools of creating creating
new tools every day
yeah i'm i'm less excited about you know
the other other stuff the most sexy
stuff the deep learning and that's i
think i think it's also important but
the production eyes of your code i think
that's what i'm really excited about
awesome yeah and i've seen a few
great talks that you've given for
meetups on that too so we'll be sure to
sure to share those links with people
too
while we're waiting for a few questions
to come in from the audience i know
something that's come up quite a bit on
these calls is
how leaders handle that transition from
an individual contributor to a manager
role
and i know this is something that you've
experienced as well and i'm i'm curious
to chat more about this and and what
it's been like for you
yeah so i
i think you know the starting point that
i i love to code
and as an individual contributor you you
do a lot of coding especially in half
and
when i
did started do the transition to manager
i thought that i could continue to code
not as much as but
at least like you know half of my time
and then in
during the transition realized that you
need to give away some of your coding
and you know the trade-off that you
start to
someone that
has a passion to coding
uh it was i think
you know
took me a while to recognize that
i just need to
do less of the coding and focus on the
important stuff you don't want to be the
bottleneck that people are waiting for
prs and you're just intermitting all
days
and
you know
so that was the tough part but then like
you
as a manager i think your goal is to
help
the other data scientists to
do the work uh so i think it's also
important
uh so that's i think the thread of the
new
moving to do like a data science scoping
uh
and general project management
but how time is there
doing less coding if i for my experience
how did you actually
make that transition then was it also
like by doing some of this stuff in your
free time and working on open source
packages does that help you with that
that was my you know my
running you know my free time to do more
yeah i started to do more coding my free
time it's like the
you're afraid to
lose the connection with the ground
right that you are starting to dwell
stuff and you're disconnecting from what
happening on
you know the first time well the
important stuff are happening
i
and i enjoy it so it's the combination
of the two um
[Music]
so
i you know i what was my
runway to do more on my free time more
open source but i think over time it
will be it will reduce that
life right you need to recognize that
you need if you want to go to management
that's
the cost that you need to pay
yeah and i see an anonymous question
that just came in around this did did
you know that you wanted to make that
jump to management or was it just the
right opportunity
how did you make that decision to become
a manager
i i i knew from the first place that
that's the you know from career
perspective this is where i want to go
but i think i didn't realize
you know when i saw my manager that is
he's not the data science but uh
he's all day in meetings
i thought because he's you know he's
from the more from the business side but
as the data science manager
you still going to do
um
you know part of the time coding and be
involved
but then like
in in really short time i realized that
i spent most of my time in meeting um
so it's you know
it was for me it was a process of
one year doing this transition
uh
that i
at some point i i
told my manager i cannot
you know continue to maintain the
project that i maintained before and i
i need to be a full-time manager to not
to be the bottleneck for my team so
i i feel that's kind of like the
the
the year transition that i had until i
you know i can say that now i'm
fully data science manager
less doing
coding what would you say is one of the
most difficult things then of of being a
manager
um
i think that you
um
you need to you know you need to
understand better the business
as a manager it's expect more um
than you before with the ict
uh so it's another transition
um
[Music]
and yeah i think that's kind of like uh
you know it's an additional
to understand the biggest the biggest
picture
it was also something that
needed to be done
yeah
and
i see another anonymous question that
just came in
um thinking about
hiring and i know we chatted about this
briefly but what kind of skills would
you look in look for in a candidate
and how does that vary based on
seniority so entry data scientist to
senior
so
generally i'm not you know not
you know that's my opinion uh
also when when you are having a team of
our users
you
at the center point you want to hire
people you know that you don't want to
during the recruiting you don't want to
evaluate skills you want to be
beyond the starting day you know the
interview process that you know those
people
are good our programmer and you can
focus on
the important stuff right the
fit for the team and um
the
how people take a business problem and
translate it into data science solutions
so
that's that's i feel like it's important
as a when you're hiring people
uh is to
be able
to articulate like that you know
starting a job description
uh to write a very clear job description
that you are looking for for example our
users and what are the skills
and then
you know we're looking at
i'm looking at this at the github
if there is if not so i'm trying to find
you know good evidence
for people that they about their own
background and this is kind of like
one of the challenging things that not
all people have
have the time to go and
maintain the github so
but having a github is providing good
visibility about some skills
and the other thing is like i know the
the first question
you know after we are leaving our
skills and the statistical skills inside
like
i usually i want you know the way i
think of it like is it is this person is
someone i want
to sit in the morning and have coffee
uh
it is like the general feed for the team
right we have a
good culture
so it's a general fit for the culture
and then the business you know the
ability to understand the business
problem it's important uh be able to be
independent so that's just i think the
time i
no matter the role i think it's
important
um things that you should look at
yeah and i i think it's so important
that you've also been in that position
position too so
being someone applying to a bunch of
different jobs and trying to figure out
like what's the best way to get noticed
by certain companies as well or to have
your skills show through
and i think it'd be really helpful for
people here today to kind of hear that
process you went through too
yeah so so you know we talked about
before uh
so when i when so
more with a bit of a background when i
graduate my master's i i was kind of
like i was originally planning to go to
phd
and last moment i decided not to
continue and then i was oh my god i need
to find
[Music]
a job
and it was a short kind of like a
short notice
and i found myself that i'm
um you know i wasn't prepared
um
so i realized that
when you're applying to tons of jobs and
you know barely get response the way to
get you know
visibility is to create to rebrand
myself if you have a certain skills but
you're not rebranding yourself you are
you can easily can get lost
so i think i think that the rebranding
is super important you know it could be
through the open source
um
social media
um and other
other
you know platform
um that's what drove me to start to do
the
or one of the things drove me to stop to
go to the open source and then like also
enjoy it so it's kind of like
was a fun experience
um
so i yes i i have a few people that i'm
mentoring and always i'd look at you
know make sure that you are
showing the world your skills it's you
know you can be very talented but if
you're not telling it
and you're not sharing it so
it's it's very hard for people to
recognize it
so i think that's kind of like the you
know
the starting the starting point
do you think one of the best ways of
doing that is also contributing to our
packages or what way was
what was most successful for you
so
i think there is the person that hired
me
on this call and uh i remember when i i
joined
uh
my my role as data science at apple uh
the first thing he told me that
uh
there were you know 1 000 people applied
for this role but you were the only one
that we could go and see on your github
that
you know time series and forecasting
um
so
i think it is
you know it's the visibility it's
provided great visibility if you are
interested to go to some domain let's
say that you are interested in
classification or regression
uh so writing about it's not
you don't need to start to develop
packages you can start with like you
know there is the daily coding in
linkedin which is a great
i i enjoy what
um you know those junior people that
either in school or right after school
doing i enjoy to see what they're doing
some of them are very creative and
it's provided a lot of visibility and
it's also open eyes
about their work
and it's also challenging you to learn
new stuff um
[Music]
so yes um that's one way but it's not
the only way you know writing articles
so
i think that's worked for me uh you know
certain people have
certain talent so you should feel what
works for you and then go with this
route
but i think
in any way creating the visibility is
important
i'm
curious from the audience as well if
this is something that you've
experienced too or something that people
are starting to do
um you can
i'll jump in if that's all right um
i think i 100 agree i think i mean
romney's uh
spot on with this i've i've certainly
found like in for my
career that being in like
healthcare and like working with like
sensitive data that ends up being a
little bit difficult with like what
people can kind of expose on github
because a lot of my contributions have
always been behind a
uh the corporate github and and in
private repositories for obvious
security reasons which makes it kind of
difficult that isn't to say i i couldn't
like do something and be public about it
and i think that that would be the
advice i would give to people i always
like to see as rami says uh people's
kind of like pet projects um
no matter how big or how small so um but
it but just that i wanted to just add
that nuance sometimes people come from
industries that are a little bit
more difficult like the data might not
be so readily available and stuff like
that
yeah and this is sometimes challenging
to find you know people
that are in this world that they cannot
share the code
or they don't have the time just to go
and
you know create their own github
fancy github
um
so you know when you when you're reading
resumes
you should also not buy yourself only
by looking at the data
but also try to
to find between the lines
if there are other stuff that you know
those people
are good at or you can identify the
skills that you're looking
but definitely
having a github it's you know
it's very
it's i think github is the new reason
where
uh oh i think that in
in schools they should
advocate the students to use more github
and those tools because this is the
future it's you know it's not it's the
present um
so
definitely and one one of things like
you know
i think beyond like the selfish things
of you know contributing to open source
because you want to rebuild yourself
it's also very noble to help others
uh by building stuff i
i really believe in the open source i
think it's a
great
thing to be part of this community no
matter the language and in particular
the our language is you know i don't
need to
say how great our community here
it's not a problem it's very like
it's not the most objective the most
you know this is the hometown but
uh being part of the open source
community i think it's
it's something i found very noble
finally and i see there's a few other
questions that are coming in that are
related to this topic as well um one was
anonymous question was how do you get
more comfortable with sharing your work
and opinions on social media it seems
pretty important in today's world
um
so first i i'm
i'm
doing a
a separation between my work
and my open source contributing
contributions uh and being part of a big
corporate anything that i
i'm putting on open source i need to get
you know the legal approval from
my company but
going back to the
question
[Music]
i doing stuff that i'm
find them interesting
and i'm also
trying not to do stuff that
might be
you know controversial like for example
when i started to do the kobe 19 i just
saw it as a time series like it was
february 2020 which which was mainly in
china
and i thought okay i did some couple of
that i'm enjoying doing data
packaging
it's very commonly now
i had some you know other packages for
electricity and the us and uk
which seems to be another time series
and maybe we can do some forecast
but then like after a few days i started
to packages realized that it's something
i don't want to forecast or you know
because it could be
sending the wrong
message here and i should be careful
because this is like pandemic is
different from electricity
and i don't want to mislead people and
then people
will say oh this focus is going
this direction and use it
and i i just
you know it just stayed in the
in the domain of uh this is just data
each one can do whatever they want i'm
not going to do
any
prediction it's not my role i realized
that you know that
other folks that should this is the
professional how to predict pandemic
uh so
you know it's
it's the combination between
find a way to
do whatever you think that it's right to
do but avoid the stuff that
i know if it's a good answer to
um don't you know use the data correctly
that's like when i see in the news
you know people using data the wrong way
uh it's kind of like example of like
what we should we as a data scientist
or people that work with data should
avoid
definitely no i think i think that's a
great answer ronnie thank you for for
bringing that up too
um daniel i i see you had a question you
asked in the chat and
would love to kind of pass the mic over
to you and have you asked that
sure you you can hear me okay
yep you sound great okay um so it was
really raw me just related to uh
your comments started to start about
like
as a manager
uh being more comfortable with doing
a little bit less coding in general
uh
and my question is really like
certain places in addition to being kind
of like the the people manager project
manager
they may want you to be kind of like the
tech lead the tech fixers are the people
the the person that people turn to when
they have particular tech things that
they that they need a solution on or
where they're stuck
um and so do you think you can
do less coding as a manager
if you have like a particular other
person who is kind of taking the lead on
those tech questions
or is that like is that not feasible to
be able to be like a people manager
doing less coding
doing project management and being kind
of like the tech lead
that's that's a great question i think
if you are a diverse team
you will have the
different people with the different
domain knowledge that they could help
the team
you know that
the tech lead in a different
domain so
in my team
uh there are people that
they are
great in docker they are great in shiny
they are great in
our markdown you know so
whenever
i have a problem i i know where and
everybody know where to go
uh
and it's not the building is not on me i
cannot control you know i cannot be
detected for all those main area and i
don't think it's the manager was
the the manager or the team role is to
hire
diverse people and people from different
backgrounds and develop those skills and
let them let the room to grow in a
different direction that people to do
what they love
um
and that's creates like a very
diverse environment that if someone
gets stuck with some docker or with
shiny modules or something like this
data pipeline there is someone that you
can
go and help you
i will be very happy to help you find
the solution
i hope this is answering your question
daniel
yeah it it does it's very helpful thank
you ronnie
jen or romney in terms of the tools that
you use and this could be in a prior
role as well
did you ever face any challenges or
biases against r in the work in your
workplace or when you're looking for a
job
uh
i think there is you know there is the
bias for people that never use our
before
uh
so it's like when you're coming to a
meeting and you meet someone and it's
like oh i never
knew about r beside
you know that where the you know where
the
couple of weeks ago we met with someone
that is
a software engineer or a software
developer and like oh i
i never knew that i can do all those
stuff and it was
enlightening to you know to get this
feedback that
people were not aware and they
discovered
uh we can't like reduce this bias
i think the other the other uh
the other part is like when you have a
big team that you know you have the
people that are more best are and
the thai devils and the gt plot and the
plotly and and it's creating a great
discussions about
you know
um
which tool to use and
uh
what what is the right way or
probably there's no right way you know
each one should
use whatever they feel like
but definitely there is
a bias i think
about all
in a big company that is
you know the majority of pythonic
uh it's like why are you using up
how people don't i think most people
just don't aware what r can do or why
statistician
it's very natural
for us to use our
and i i find myself and my colleagues
explaining why isaac is a great tool for
what we're doing
but i think when people see the results
they
think directly about it so
um
yeah yeah and
in that case where you were meeting with
say a software engineer who isn't as
familiar with r
how do you communicate that or
is it by showing your work
um
it's just usually like we're explaining
you know either we are showing you know
some of the deliveries that we
we you know we created you know or
explain why us as a
as a
you know data scientists we choose our
as opposed to other tools
and you know we are using our whenever r
is the best tools to use
and if we need to use python we will use
python for other tasks where our
sls application so it's not that we are
you know we have we are we are our
fanatics and we will use we use arc is a
great tool for what we are doing
and there are other fronts that maybe
are uh as less application python this
most is stronger so we'll use python so
it's you know just choose the tools that
fit best to your work uh actually what
should not be like some religious stuff
that
we are just
using our we're just using python and
you know that's how this is pythons
we're not there um
and also some someone
texts me about batch so we're also using
batch a lot yes
and julia i see on your
your twitter
so
julia is more
exploit explanatory
we're still not there i believe that you
guys you know is the future
so i definitely see in the future that
we will
be part of the ecosystem of r
as if today
uh for example if you want to make your
r code efficient you will use the r or
ccp or you know you will call some
c plus plus or c to make your code
run faster so julia is is another tool
that can enable you
to run your code faster
and it's easy to write compared to other
languages so i definitely see that in
the future
we're going to see more julia
and i remember like in the the last uh
conference
that one of the questions in san
francisco to the last on-site
uh one of the questions to jj uh
on the i think in the opening
uh are we you know
does our students going to
incorporate julia uh in our studio and
he answered no but i feel like in
someone
in couple of years i i would see
julia also like python today becoming
part of
the our
i see it
that jira will be also
one of the citizens
of
our studio
so maybe
shifting gears a little bit i see frank
you asked a question around of
communicating to stakeholders i believe
i'm scrolling back a little bit but yeah
would you want to jump in and ask that
one yeah ronnie uh
thanks for your insights here one of the
things you mentioned and i think i got
this right and if not please correct me
but you you were saying you create
forecasts and then sometimes the users
will say well what's going to happen in
the future
um can you can you make tweaks to your
forecast because i want to consider this
in there too
and right your
[Music]
i think what you said is
your forecast is based on historical
data and history
and
there's this methodology and you don't
want to go in and manually really
dance around too much
because then it breaks your methodology
and if that if that's what you said how
do you have any tips or tricks for us
when we're communicating to folks the
difference between like hey i have this
model i have this method it works well
we've back tested
um and if i start going and taking your
intuition and assumptions user and like
messing around with that it's going to
kind of break how how it could be used
by multiple parties i'm guessing they
don't love that
so i think that you you know the first
thing is like you need to be honest
about what the focus is about what is
what are the limitations where it's
going to fail
and like for example focus is
looking at the historical and using this
token to predict but sometimes you know
like we saw it in the cover right that
uh if you look at some of the
economical indicators that either went
really up
like the
uh unemployment
or went really down like the flights or
stuff like this that no matter what your
local data cannot help you
so i think you know in the first place
setting the expectation of what the
forecast can do is important
uh definitely
making sure that you're also providing
conference intervals
on top of it i would say that um back to
your questions that typically
in a data science you would
you want to work with some business
analysts that have context about the
future
that ask the data scientists that we are
only looking at the past
we don't have this context like a let's
say if you are
working in sales that
of some product and you know that in the
future going to be some
uh campaign or going to be some
[Music]
um
a shift of a new product going to affect
the sales of your specific product and
this is where
they will do the manual adjustment and
you know they will have to
advocate to the business
why
they made those adjustments i think when
there is big uncertainty
it's good to have more than one option
uh so you can you can also you know you
can incorporate to some regression model
and you know by adding some flags and
then
uh say if i move this leg up a little
bit or down like a think about like a
some kind of like a
spline that you can say
the spine is going to be
longer than then you know you're
creating a longer range or shorter edge
and they say the
different scenarios
so i think having conflict what if
analysis when you've you know when
this token is not enough it's probably
my favorite option
but i think it's also you need to be
honest
uh with the stakeholders about what the
limitation of the forecast
that you know
some people think it's their sciences
are magic
and i think it's important to
to set the expectation that we are
not politician it is science and there
are limitations right this tokel can
tell us
some story but you know the future
sometimes is as different
yeah
i love that i think a mistake we we
often make is that um
we go through classes and we go through
courses and we
believe that there's a problem out there
and then there's one model to solve that
problem like what technique do i know
that i can apply to this problem and
then like we'll call it a day we solved
it but what you said reminds me of the
idea of like we talk a lot about um
ensemble models
but there's also like the idea of
ensemble perspectives
so if we're working with users and we
like hey yeah so there's a forecast
model here it has its limitations let's
be honest about that like you said but
then here's another way to look at it
and here's another way to look at it um
i think that is where
us as a group on this call can really
turn the tide and get users
on board
yeah you're charging ahead and i think
typically you see that data science
scientists work better when they have
some business unless that help them
to articulate the problem and you know
guide them with
well uh some some of the
insights about
the business that you know just looking
at it that you want you might not have
so i think it's important to combine
uh get this help with some
someone from the business
agreed
olly i see you um just had a question
there as well around the explainability
of models would you want to jump in and
ask that
yeah absolutely
first of all thank you for your
fantastic insights remy
my name is oli and i'm working with data
at the city of radaric
i had a question regarding when you
operationalize models and
so i face that often when we have to
have a discussion with our stakeholders
uh what are these models telling us like
the explainability of models like
inferring like how the predictors are
actually affecting your response
and
and i find that to be a fascinating
subject like
um
when when you need to work with
stakeholders you need to have a
discussion on hey did you know that this
predictor is
influencing your response in this way
and i can show you in a graph like if it
would be a linear model it's easy to
explain but
i'm curious about this in general and
especially in time series modeling with
what you're doing like do you have to
have these discussions with your
stakeholders at apple do you need to
um exhibit the the outputs or the models
in a way that
um
like how the predictors are influencing
the response
to show that graphically on a graph or
in story or
i feel like those things are important
within the organization and even though
it's
obvious to the data scientists do you
have any comments on that
thoughts that's that's a good question
without referring to my work or anything
like this but generally i think that
they're going to be
a couple
two type of stakeholders or generally
two types of stakeholders the one they
uh not necessarily care about the type
of models they you know they care about
the results and they want to see
something you know like some forecast
that
they can use the other type that they
type of stakeholders that actually
they they want to know more about the
models
that use there may not be statistician
or you know
background with the modeling but they
they either need to articulate it to
other to their
manager so they need to present it and
use it so that they want to make sure
that they are understanding the model
the methodology
so i think in this case it's it's
nice
to do some you know
to take
the time and have meeting to explain
them
i'm using uh three type of models so
example i'm using a lima this is how
arima
model is working or this is how a linear
regression is model using if you know if
you are users like coming with a shiny
example that you can
uh
you know say if i'm now changing this
parameter this is how
you know affect the output this is our
calculated seasonality
um i think that the best tool
to explain people is data visualization
it's you know if you combine combined
with some shiny application of or
something similar that they can see the
interaction
of the model with the data and now when
you change some parameter it's affect
the output i think it's a uh
you know easy to explain and
get them on board
yes absolutely i think that's a really
good point and
it presents you
with an opportunity to
have a discussion with your stakeholders
in a way you
that you can both relate to
and
because in my at least in my work i'm
not an expert
in the business domains of my
stakeholders
and but i'm an expert in data so so we
need to have this common ground to have
a conversation and and i feel like this
is the way in
right
and not to be overly technical but
present it in a graph and to anything
yes
it can
lead to further insights into the
underlying um processes
in the data like statistical processes
all right good thank you
we're really inside too
apologies if i'm pronouncing your name
wrong i i see you asked a few questions
in there and i don't want to assume
priority um so i'd love to have you ask
your favorite question as well
and i've actually i've enjoyed the
discussion thus far because i'm in uh i
just became a manager this month
actually
so
the
the
trajectory that rami has uh traversed
over the last uh
i mean at the beginning uh is similar to
mine i'm very technical in my day-to-day
job so i'm finding it hard to
be a manager and leave the technical
work to the other team members so i i
think i would like some additional
pointers from ramy on that aspect
definitely and congrats on the new role
as well
congratulations again thank you
um
yes i it's okay if i understand
correctly like what is the
the question is
um
what did
okay
so the question is uh what is the
you know the transformation from
to management
what are the
[Music]
yes
so you know i know if you have a
if you are carrying with you the project
that you managed you know you were part
of the people they did before
those those projects uh as a
individual contributor i think it's the
make sure that you are
find someone that will
continue
uh
i think you know this is where i found
myself continue to do what i did
before carrying my projects but also
start to be a full-time manager and then
like in in terms of time management was
very challenging so i think thinking
about transition of your past project
assuming that
you still maintain them
uh is important um
and
[Music]
thinking about um
[Music]
your time right
there's
maybe
at least the beginning you're trying to
do
to
do about your your previous uh
task and also the new task and then
there is a limit of time how much you
can
walk
crazy hours and
a long time you will burn yourself so
that's
i feel my main advice try to make sure
there is a good transition
and focus on
the important stuff as a manager like uh
you know make sure that your team
has whatever they need to success
thank you and and there's another
question related to this as well from
earlier being more of a technical person
did you always have those managing
skills or people skills
or did you have to learn them
um
i think i have i had some of them and
you know don't you know you always
learning new stuff
um
so i did
before my
you know my life at the data science i
did some management roles so
working
working with people
and you know the
ability to
manage a team
it's something that's
i think i had before but also data
science will be different so i
was also learning experience for for my
end
um i think what you know for example
scoping data science project was
something that i learned
i would say i don't want to say that way
but it was the hard way
this year
so there are some skills that i came
with and some skills that i learned
the process and mainly related to
scoping
and
apologies if other people know exactly
what that looks like but i but i don't
so
what does that look like scoping a data
science project
i think the the the first thing is to
understand the business problem
and
make sure that the base farm is defined
correctly and going back to the
you know what we
uh the question from frankly about
um
you know
working with the focus but like you need
to have some business on the list that
or someone you know the terms you know
business analyst or data analyst that
define what this problem that we are
trying to solve
without it you it's easy to get lost
um
so
[Music]
you know scoping is is translate
the biggest problem into data science
features and i think
there are two
in the projects that i i
from my perspective are two challenges
in a data science project one is to
define the business problem
the other the second one probably more
challenging is to find the data
uh that
required to solve the business problem
if
if you are able to
solve those two
the modeling part and you know
it's the
the easy part and it's like
like the
70 30 or 80
20 percent
uh locate time location between the data
and the modeling
that's i think
the reality
so
if you want articulate the business
problem correctly it's easy to get lost
and i think that's kind of like the
the most important
part when you're starting a project
thank you and
just because a few of these questions
have come up so far i i think it may be
helpful and maybe to ask the audience as
well if you have
resources maybe that you think would be
helpful for a new manager
in terms of like learning those people
skills as well
i'd love to hear
what has been useful for everyone
or if anybody wants to jump in as well
i see ollie said five dysfunctions of a
team one other question ramy that just
came in um anonymously was have you
faced a situation where a user is
looking for
causal inferences from a predictive
model
if so how do you deal with that
um
not necessarily causal inference but
more
you know the
users that
they try to understand
the
mechanism of the model
and this is where i would go and
sit with
that
stakeholder and
expand my methodology
will try to do it as simple as possible
i always advocate to use
you know
if you can use something simple
use it don't
it's not necessarily to be fancy
more offensive it's not necessary better
results
um
so
yeah um
try to explain like how regression is
working to and how we use it to solve
some problem
or different model
is something that i would do
and again the best mode the best method
is like to create our markdown
with the data
and with you know going through the
process and use some shiny components
that's my favorite tool
i think i saw a linkedin post that you
had about that as well like you don't
have to just use a deep learning model
just because
and so
you know is usually like when i'm
talking
in a meetups on production which i did
i had two of those in the in the last uh
two weeks uh
i always say that you know
if someone
come to me and say like i can create a
fancy deep
uh learning models or some machine
learning models that's that's great
but if someone will come to me i can
deploy my linear regression in
production so this is a god
so i think that
um you know in the data science world
today at least
um
[Music]
it's more important
[Music]
that you can be able to take your work
into production
then
[Music]
do fancy stuff like if i can see my
projection my progress as a data science
like i feel like that i had a normal
curve like as any
other data science in the room here that
when i was
just starting as a really junior
i was into this deep learning machine
and i was curious about it
and
over time
i realized that if i
if i need to run a model like to
for one hour two hours to optimize it
and probably get the same results as i
would run linear regression
uh
it's probably not worth it just for the
sake of saying that i did
something fancy and then if i cannot
communicate it to
others
uh like you know deploy it in a
dashboard or you know deploy it
somewhere it's uh
it's
worthless because you know you're not
getting the recognition so
today i think
being
like a full stack data scientist that
you can
take your walk into production and it's
super important
thank you rami
i see rob
h you've asked a question in the chat as
well would you want to ask that one live
sure um yeah just
talking to
lots of data scientists and
organizations it seems
that often not always but often the
highest value problems tend to be really
complex
and then sort of the dichotomy of the
simpler problems but they tend to be
lower value
so like just curious how you navigate
that
those priorities to make sure that you
tackle because you talked you touched on
it before that's what made me think of
it you talked about the high sort of the
big problems
um
how do you make sure that the
organization is actually tackling those
that's a
good question uh
i i would say that
you know
my my approach is always to
approach staff with the most
simple and approachable
solution um
[Music]
and
you know i always
actually looking at the hanging fruit
like if i see that the business all the
problem that
there are you know that there are and
usually there are more problems that we
can actually solve
because we're always bounded by
resources
i always love to go for first to the
hanging fruit and start with those ones
because this is where i get my quick
wins
and then move to the complex
it's better to have something than
nothing it's another
common phrase that our team is using
and iteration
um so you don't need to
solve the problem
completely
you know to spend one year
just to solve a problem if it's a
complex start with something simple you
know deliver after one to two and keep
it right and improve it
uh at least you deliver something and
you know the business start to see some
value
um
rather than just do
a long research and maybe
get something uh after you i think that
there is a trade-off right
as long as you can articulate that it's
not perfect and you need more time but
you going to iterate and it's a process
so and the business understand i think
that's what i i like to do
there are some cases right if you are
and it's not my domain but if you are
delivering a product
for end users so then this is where you
definitely need to
address the complexity
and make sure that you solve it before
you release it but that's a different
domain and i'm not in the domain
i hope this is answering questions
yeah thank you
rami a question
from earlier
was have you had to teach our skills to
members of your team and do you have any
tips for doing that
so typically they teach me new stuff
i'm fortunate that i am surrounding it
with very small people that they are
you know we have lunch and learns you
know actually
um at ten o'clock i'm jumping to an
internal meetup
uh that we have
uh so we're trying to do as many as uh
those internal
uh luncheon and if someone came and say
oh i
i learn i solve how to you know i learn
how to
[Music]
create a pipeline with that tool or i
learn how to build this with that tool
or something like this i
so it's like the immediate response in
our slack is lunch and learn
uh
and so
we're trying to create a
environment that we share the knowledge
and documentation is very important if
you learn something we have like a big
book down that we
any neutral that we're using we are just
documenting it trying at least the
document not always doing a good job at
least i'm probably the worst in
documented but
um that's the culture we're trying to
create um to make sure that we are
sharing the knowledge
that's awesome that you all do that and
i know one of the questions on a prior
hangout was around like getting people
to talk as well and like how do you find
people to speak at these
and i love that you just say you answer
on slack lunch and learn topic
seems like a great way of getting topics
too
there's a general question that came in
anonymously as well which can be open to
to anybody
but do you think as an our first
analyst or data scientist you could
manage a team of non-r users
it should be
as long as you're open
um
and you you know like let's say that if
tomorrow i need to manage a
team that i'll fight on you probably i
should learn some
python
because i think it's you know as long
as
as a manager as i mentioned before you
are doing less coding but like i do
review code i do
i want to
you know when we have a code review
uh you still want to make sure that you
know you understand what other folks are
doing
so i think
in a if you are still in
that management level
you should probably
be open to learn the other language if
it's a python or any other language
to
be involved and understand what the
folks are doing
and i know you you've already mentioned
that
team users both are in python but
someone asked can you give a general
example of when you would use r or when
to use python
so most of the time i'm using alcos
you know from the data
when you're loading that you're putting
the default apis like the easy way is to
you know
put it with and process it with dplyr
and all the other great tools
um
the case that i will use for example i'm
using a lot of bash
thanks to denton that is also here in
this call
[Music]
and when you try to automate our code in
some
command line
environment and this is where you know
it's easier to do automation
uh called different
files
or if you're having some eml file that
with the manifest of some job
um instead of doing multiple steps it's
just you know we're calling it bash
script they're doing those steps or
in a docker when i'm believing in doctor
i also like to
use bash to automate so that's example i
had some examples like
if you need to pull some s3
objects
the paths i used to use to
there is a python package library called
23 so
it was kind of like the native
uh library to pull s3 objects so i use
this
but mostly i'm using um
i know we're getting to
the top of the hour here and you may
have a lunch and learn to run to i'm
yeah
i'm hosting this lunch you're hosting it
okay so real real quickly if people have
follow-up questions what's the best way
to get in contact with you or to network
with you is it linkedin
yeah i'm on linkedin twitter um
yeah just
my linkedin is probably
the platform that i'm most active
and i could share your linkedin here
really quickly but you are also very
easy to find there if people just search
your name
um but thank you so much rami i really
appreciate it i know you have to run but
great insights and thank you for for
jumping on and joining us
looking forward to to next week as well
i'm sorry they know there were a few
questions we didn't get to
but we can look at those and maybe carry
them over to to next week's hangout too
thank you so much thank you all have a
great rest of the day
you